we're lost in a cloud
with too much rain what was it like
watching Austin on stage and during this
movie it was mind-blowing truly
mind-blowing and so spot on and so
authentic Austin Butler thinks the late
Lisa Marie Presley here are the nominees
for performance by an actor in a leading
role after his first Oscar nomination
Austin Butler and Elvis
details The Hollywood Reporter quote I
just wish Lisa Marie was here to
celebrate today with us the movie is
important it's not just because it's my
father Austin calls the only child of
Elvis Presley the most straightforward
and supportive person and says he's
grateful for their time together and
getting three years of exploring the
life of her father
thank you
this follows Lisa Marie's celebration of
life on Sunday Lisa Marie Presley was an
icon a role model a superhero to many
people all over the world
Austin went to the Graceland ceremony to
pay his respects our heart is broken
Lisa we all love you two days before her
death Lisa Marie was with ET at the
Golden Globes praising Austin's
performance I had to take like five days
to process it because it was so
incredible
he took home the trophy that night to be
in that room full of all those people
that I've admired so much the Presleys
who have now welcomed me into their
family in such a beautiful way and I
just feel so endlessly grateful to them
that they
provided this space for me to somehow
try to capture the essence of this man
that they that means so much to them and
that they love so much you know
also on Tuesday Warner Brothers
announces the Elvis movies headed back
to theaters commemorating the biopics
total of eight Oscar nods I'm ready
ready to fly Elvis is so loved and so
iconic it's a weight like I never felt
before and there's a responsibility to
his family and his tribute Austin says
the real prize was looking in Lisa
Marie's eyes after she first saw the
film quote she told me how much it meant
to her I'll really cherish that for the
rest of my life and there's so many
misconceptions about him there's so many
ideas of him so I felt such a
responsibility to bring the humanity
[Music]
tonight
I wasn't ready for what I did I really
wasn't best kind of left me alone in the
theater the first time I saw it so I
kind of watched it by myself
embraced myself and when baz came to get
me after the film I just fell into him
in tears just and I could barely I
couldn't speak he had to like walk me in
my car I was like you know
so we saw it again last night and you
know it's just you want to keep watching
it you want to keep watching this one
foreign